there are guys that are very good from
stage
very good from stage
and it makes you believe they're better
one-on-one but they suck one-on-one suck
101 they're good stage right so there's
three levels too there's stage there's
group setting u un5 and there's one on
one okay
and then there are those guys that are
very good one-on-one but they suck on
stage
i used to think the guy on stage would
build the biggest business
but it's the guy that was the best at
101 that built the biggest business
because he knew how to get things done
and he would move things forward so the
one-on-one unfortunately none of us can
gauge because there is no camera on
one-on-one so we don't know how biden is
one-on-one we don't know how trump is
one-on-one but obviously when trump was
doing one-on-one
nothing was happening isis disappeared
putin was calm nothing was going on
there so the power of the one-on-one
unfortunately we will never be able to
gauge ever because there's no cameras in
the one-on-one